hey you guys flickers of fear time and
we're still doing monster march now
there's a couple reasons that i finally
got around to doing this movie for some
reason i thought we had already reviewed
this but i guess not
so i was like okay uh yeah this is uh
cloverfield from 2008.
now as you can see
i guess like we were at fye
uh in the mall and this was probably
like a year ago maybe more
and they were selling off a bunch of old
horror dvds for like a buck or i don't
know like three or five dollars or
something like that and it was super
super cheap so i was just kind of like
ah what the hell so i went in there and
bought like a big pile of them uh we've
reviewed some of them so far and this
was one of the ones that i bought
because at the time that i bought this i
don't think i'd ever seen cloverfield
but i knew like everybody uh talked
about it like you know being a really
good monster movie and a really good
found footage movie
so i was like okay well i should pick
that up and uh one of these days we'll
get around to reviewing it and i thought
we got around to reviewing it but i
guess we didn't
so then i thought to myself well since
i'm doing monster movies this month and
i already own this then i might as well
pull the trigger on it also i didn't
realize this until i started
thinking about reviewing this movie but
this was directed by
matt reeves who very famously just
directed the brand new the batman
so i thought oh well that's a fortuitous
coincidence all right i didn't do that
on purpose really but uh but yeah so he
did the um planet of the apes movies uh
two like after this but this was kind of
uh one of sort of one of his first ones
i guess and the one that sort of like
put his name on the map i suppose so
cloverfield
this is very interesting like i said
this came out in 2008 it's produced by
jj abrams now apparently like the idea
for this
came from
jj abrams uh has said and i actually
watched like a lot of the behind the
scenes stuff on the dvd as well he was
like i was in uh tokyo with my son
and we were in like all these toy stores
and [ __ ] like that and he's like and i
kept seeing like all this godzilla stuff
and he was sitting there thinking man
wouldn't it be cool if
we had in america we had like a big like
kaiju
just like they have in japan because
look how
look what a cultural impact like that
big giant monster has had you know when
did the first godzilla come out like 70
years ago something like that and
there's still it still has such cultural
relevance and so he essentially wanted
to do
like an american kaiju movie but with
our own kind of like spin on it and to a
large extent i think he was very
successful in doing that
now i think i've mentioned on some of my
other reviews
i'm not a huge fan of found footage
generally i don't really like to say
that across the board because
honestly i'll watch pretty much any
genre if it's a good movie and so i
don't have any like complete aversion to
any
genre or even any uh you know horror sub
genre in particular but there are ones
that i like more than others
and found footage ones i don't usually
seek those out unless somebody tells me
oh this is a really good one and i think
that maybe i think uh some of that it's
not just because of like the shaky cam
and stuff like that doesn't really
bother me um although i can understand
if it does because this one has some of
that too where
you know if you're like prone to getting
dizzy or nauseated or like motion
sickness or something like that then i
can see how you wouldn't want to watch
it because it does have a lot of that
going on
that doesn't really bother me all that
much though i think what bothers me
about a lot of found footage movies
is that
you know you have the whole problem of
like verisimilitude why would somebody
be filming this so i think if you have
like a good that's why i tend to prefer
the the sub sub genre of found footage
which is like mockumentary
because then at least
you know when [ __ ] starts going sideways
you know they have as well they're
making a documentary they're actually
supposed to be documenting something so
there is a reason for them to film it
this one has a little bit of that
cloverfield does but i'm gonna give this
one a pass because
i could kind of see this happening it
did this didn't kind of there were a
couple times where i was like yeah
you're running away from a giant monster
might want to turn that camera off but
honestly i think it was handled so well
that it didn't really stand out to me
that it wasn't something that you would
be
doing and the guy behind the camera the
character's name who's hud
he did actually say you know i need to
document this people are gonna know want
to know what happened on this day and
stuff like that and i can totally
because honestly
yeah this was 2008 nowadays i think it's
even more likely nowadays that if a
giant monster started rampaging through
an american city everybody would be
filming that stuff so even if they were
running away from it because they're
just like holy [ __ ] you know what i mean
so i don't really think it's that
i don't think it's that unbelievable to
be honest maybe it was more unbelievable
in 2008 but now it is absolutely it's
not so what you have in cloverfield now
this movie this is kind of amazing
because this was made just goes to show
and i've brought this up on many other
shows you don't need a big budget i mean
25 million that's a lot of money but in
movie making terms it's like you know
nothing that's like a drop in the bucket
uh this cost 25 million dollars to make
and made
a shit-ton i think it made 178 million
or something like that it was like a
massive massive success
one of the things too that i thought was
actually pretty brilliant about this and
i'm gonna go so far as to say maybe and
this is a good movie i really do like
this movie a lot but i think the viral
marketing campaign was even better than
the movie buzz
because
this did
i mean you know blair witch project had
done it too like in 1999 so this
obviously wasn't the first movie to do
that even though it's one of the kind of
earlier examples
but the viral marketing campaign that
they did for this was actually pretty
genius uh they did the first trailer
which i think was attached to the
transformers movie
and the first trailer that they showed
didn't say the name of the movie
basically all it had was just some
footage of like a surprise party and
then
something bad like happening you know on
this footage like explosions and [ __ ]
like that but it didn't tell you what it
was it didn't tell you it was a monster
movie if it was a disaster movie or you
know or anything or you know it's
there's a possibility that it could have
been about 9 11 because i'll get into
that in a little bit too
but it didn't really say anything all it
had at the end it didn't have the title
it just had like the date that it was
coming out and then if you went to the
website which was the date which i think
was 1 1808 or something like that and if
you went to that website
then it had
all of this like supplementary material
and it had kind of all now it was 2008
so myspace was still a thing which is
funny because
myspace it's weird because 2008 when i
think about 2008 i'm like oh that
doesn't seem like that long ago but i
was like
myspace that seems like forever ago so
it was
it was actually kind of shocking to me
that learned to learn that myspace was
still a thing in 2008 because i thought
it was like
gone like way before that but you know
what i mean my sense of time is like all
skewed but anyways uh so there were
my space profiles for all the characters
in the movie
and there was also a link to a website
which was supposedly like a japanese
company that made this
drink called slusho
uh which was kind of like a whole other
thing so it was almost presented like an
arg
and it had kind of like all these clues
now they tried to keep it super super
secret and like i said if you look at
like all the behind the footage uh the
behind-the-scenes footage of the making
of this movie and some of it they did do
on a sound stage but some of it they did
actually film like in the streets of new
york city and so they had to put out
like all these fake titles i think one
of you know one of them was cheese one
of them was gray shots they had like all
these different titles because they
really didn't want anybody finding out
about it because even back in 2008
you know the internet was still enough
of a thing that every time you tried to
make a movie everybody was
knew about it like somebody would spill
some information and it'd be all over
the internet
but because
they started out with this mysterious
trailer that didn't tell you what it was
and then there was this mysterious
website that had all these links to like
this other company and like these
myspace profiles so everybody got really
interested in what the [ __ ] is this like
what is this new movie that's coming out
uh everybody knew it was a movie but
um there was some speculation maybe it's
a new godzilla movie maybe it's a
cthulhu movie which that would have been
cool but um you know but it wasn't that
spoiler alert but yeah so it wasn't that
but uh there was all kind of like uh
speculation about what it was
and then finally i think when um
beowulf came out they actually did like
the second trailer that had the uh the
title of it on there and i can't really
remember if that title i think that one
kind of made it a little bit more clear
that it was a monster movie i don't so i
don't know too like like i said the the
viral marketing campaign for this was
actually pretty brilliant and i think it
really did go a long way toward getting
a lot of people interested because it
was a mystery behind it that you could
like solve
and but i just so i don't know
because i didn't see this at the time
and i wasn't really aware like i'd kind
of heard about the hype but i was just
kind of like yeah whatever i wasn't
really in on it
so i don't know if people that got
really super into trying to figure out
what this movie was if when they
actually saw the movie if they were like
disappointed i didn't really get that
impression
i'm sure there was probably i think
there was a little bit of a backlash but
honestly this did find it like very very
well
and it was like actually pretty
critically acclaimed also
so
i guess there wasn't too much of a back
i guess people weren't like all that
disappointed that it wasn't cthulhu or
godzilla or whatever the hell
so what happens in this movie
at the very beginning you have uh this
character named rob and there is there
some footage of him he's filming
this girl named beth and you're led to
presume that their boyfriend or
girlfriend or you know they just started
dating or something like that and you
know they're being very lovey-dovey she
says she's never been to coney island
and he's like oh my god we have to go
and then there's like some footage of
that like interspersed so i thought that
was actually a really clever thing to do
because they're kind of opening with
these characters
and you don't find out until a little
bit later that this was actually what
was originally on the tape and then the
tape that has the monster footage on it
was uh when it got like the original
footage got taped over but so like every
time
you know hud who's filming the actual
monster footage like would push stop or
like rewind or something like that like
there was a little bit of the old
footage still on there of rob and beth
and it was really good because that
those little pieces of it being
interspersed and they're like
re-contextualized like everything you
had seen up to that point so i thought
that was a really good uh kind of clever
way of
kind of uh adding some emotional
resonance to it i guess
so uh rob
is you find out uh the the footage of
him and beth like sleeping together
they don't show that on the actual thing
it's just like the next morning you know
what i mean like the conversation
and uh that happened like a month prior
so then you find out that rob actually
got a promotion to
the head of this company the same
japanese company i can't remember what
the name of it is right now the one that
makes a slusho they don't say that in
the movie this is only like in the
supplemental material like i said
there's a lot of stuff that
that's kind of what's cool about this
movie is that you can just like watch it
as like a cool like found footage
monster movie but if you want to kind of
like delve into the lore and stuff
there's all kind of and i'll talk about
the sequels too in a minute but
uh there's all kind of this other
supplemental material like all this [ __ ]
that's going on uh including the fact
that the company that makes slusho the
company that rob works for in the movie
might have been responsible for the
monster which is called clover busting
out and like taking you know what i mean
so there's like a little bit of that
going on too but you like i said that's
not in the movie because the movie is
presented as coming from
just average new yorkers who
are thrust into this situation and have
no idea what's going on which to me i
think makes the movie a lot
scarier and a lot more like visceral
because this is exactly the situation
that you would be in if something like
this happened you wouldn't have any
[ __ ] idea what the hell was going on
you would just be like running around
trying to keep your ass from getting
eaten by a giant monster and again i've
said this on many other occasions i
think like stuff that's unknown is like
way scarier or stuff if you just like
get get little glimpses of it and i
think this did a really good job
of doing that i it's probably i don't
know i kind of feel like it would have
been a little bit more effective if i
had if i'd maybe seen it at the time
because by the time i saw it i already
knew what the cloverfield monster looked
like because i'd seen so many other
stills and like other reviews of it and
stuff like that but that said you know
that can't really be helped and i still
thought it was like a very effective for
all that
so rob works for this company he got a
promotion and he's actually moving to
japan
so all of his friends have this big
going away party for him like a surprise
party
now
uh hud actually rob's brother whose name
what's his name jason i think rob's
brother is actually supposed to be
filming all of the people at the party
like um he's making like a record of all
the people at the party like saying
goodbye to rob or like saying how much
they like him they're gonna put it all
together like a wedding video or some
[ __ ] like that so they're gonna do that
but jason doesn't really want to do it
so he fobs it off on his friend hud
who's actually played by a tj miller uh
who i think is in the deadpool movies
actually he's a comedian also um and he
provides a lot of
comic relief for this which is i didn't
find it annoying but it's right on the
it's right on the edge because i kind of
i've he felt like a real person to me
you know well obviously he's a real
person but i'm saying his character felt
like a real person to me where he's like
the guy that is that's his defense
mechanism like all of this horrible
scary like unbelievable [ __ ] is
happening and he's just trying to like
keep himself
sane by sort of
making like awkward jokes about
everything so like i said it's not
how you feel about his character
uh you know that's gonna be up to you
but
and i could and i could kind of see how
maybe some people would find it annoying
but
i mean he very much seemed like a real
person and that seemed like
some [ __ ] that the real person would say
if this was going on uh you know trying
to just like make light of it because he
doesn't know what else to do you know
what i mean
so hud gets roped into doing this uh
this filming thing of all these people
the party even though he doesn't really
know anybody that well and he's just
kind of like oh man i don't want to do
this just you know but uh he does end up
doing it he's a trooper now he happens
to have a crush on
this other girl who comes to the party
whose name is marlena he knows her i
guess like he's met her a bunch of times
but she like barely remembers him and
she doesn't even really know the other
people at the party all that well she's
like there with a friend of a friend who
knows them
so she's kind of there and
hud uh using the camera kind of like
trying to like creep in on her a little
bit like hey i'm filming all this stuff
and she's just like yeah i barely know
them it's like
you know get the hell away from me
weirdo it's like that kind of thing but
he just keeps like filming her like
following around and stuff not in a
creepy creepy way but it is a little bit
creepy gonna say but it's more awkward
than creepy
so uh you get like some drama coming up
with this family or family this party
because it ends up turns out that rob uh
who
again had slept with beth like we see
that footage at the beginning but what
happened during that ensuing month was
that i guess he sort of like ghosted her
or blew her off like after that happened
because apparently they'd been like
friends before that
and then they slept together and it was
everyone was like oh my god like
scandalous you know what i mean because
they've been friends for such a long
time uh but he was like
sort of like low-key or like in love
with her
and she was upset that he had apparently
like blown her off like after they slept
together and so she goes i mean she
started dating someone else like as you
would and she turns up at this party
with this other dude
and so there's like some drama ensuing
uh and she was like hey you blew me off
like what the [ __ ] was i supposed to do
and he's like yeah well i was moving to
japan i didn't really want to get into
this big thing or whatever and she's
like well yeah it would have been nice
if you told me that blah blah so there
was like all that kind of stuff going on
so this is like the first like 15
minutes movie it's just this very
it you know it's them like filming a
party and then there's like some drama
and stuff and then suddenly
there's a really big crash like big bang
uh you know they look out um you know
and the power kind of flickers off and
[ __ ] and somebody's like what the [ __ ]
was that an earthquake or whatever and
so everybody kind of like runs up to the
roof of the building and they see like
kind of far away across the just across
central park across the harbor or
something like that um they see like a
big explosion and they're just like what
the [ __ ] is that what's going on over
there you know what i mean like it looks
really bad and uh you know so everything
just starts [ __ ] going to [ __ ] from
then on now like i said for a long time
you don't really know
it's a monster they don't know it's a
monster because
they just think you know it's
bombs or it's an earthquake or something
like that which obviously that's what
you would think if that really happened
uh they all run out of the building
because the building starts to [ __ ]
shake and stuff and so they go out of
there and then
this big uh the head of the statue of
liberty crashes down in the middle of
the street like right in front of the
building where they are at which point
they're like oh [ __ ] this is like really
bad whatever this is fun fact i think
that they thought they wanted to do that
with the head of the statue of liberty
because of the poster from escape from
new york which has like similar imagery
and they were kind of like doing an
homage to that i'm pretty sure i heard
jj abrams say that in one of the
interviews but yeah so that was like a
nice touch
so at that point they're just kind of
like holy [ __ ] and then hud who still
has the camera like turns toward you
know the street like down the long way
and sees
a glimpse of something
that could be a monster but you can't
really tell what it is so he's like
flipping out he's like what you know i
just saw something big and i don't know
what it was i just saw a glimpse of it
and so everyone starts flipping out and
so uh from then on
the whole the rest of the movie
is them just like
trying to get the well they try to get
everybody out of manhattan so they are
kind of steering them at first towards
the brooklyn bridge
but then uh you see kind of part of the
monster and the monster's tail like kind
of comes out and then
knocks part of the brooklyn bridge over
like which kills rob's brother jason
now at that point he's trying to call
beth the girl that you know that he had
like the big drama with because she had
actually left the party early because
they'd had like an argument
now he actually manages to get a phone
call from her in which she says that her
building was like half collapsed or she
said that she can't move and she's
trapped in her building
so at this point rob who has just seen
his brother killed like because he is
thrown off the brooklyn bridge like when
it's destroyed by the monster's tail
uh he basically kind of decides well i'm
not gonna let one more person i love die
so he says i'm going back into manhattan
and she lives in midtown i'm going back
into manhattan and i'm gonna get her
like out of the building because she
says she can't move she's trapped in her
apartment and i'm gonna save her so uh
everybody obviously thinks she's
thinks he's crazy but
hud and um
jason's
wife or girlfriend uh and marlena all
decide they're gonna go with him because
i mean rob that's his that's their
friend and they don't want him getting
so they are like okay we gotta go back
and save beth so basically everyone's
trying to get out of manhattan but they
decide to go back into manhattan to see
if they can get her out and during all
this obviously they're having to contend
with
this humongous [ __ ] monster like
stomping through the middle of [ __ ]
new york city and uh just i mean the way
they did this i really think like i said
i'm not a huge fan of found footage
because most of the time
i kind of feel like
you know and i'm not [ __ ] on like
low budget filmmakers because sometimes
that's like all you can do it's like
let's just make a found footage movie
because it's cheaper but honestly if
you're gonna do found footage i think
that you should have a reason for it to
be found footage and i think that this
has a legitimate claim
for doing that because this is like a
godzilla film
but unlike a godzilla film it's actually
framed from the perspective of just
regular ass people instead of like
scientists and military and stuff like a
godzilla film would be um so it's just
regular-ass people who really don't have
any idea what's going on and you know
everything is just like [ __ ] chaos to
them because they don't know what this
is
and i like the found footage thing
because it really
it puts you in the middle of it you can
really like
put yourself into this situation
you know because they're just at a party
and then all of a sudden
there's a giant monster ramp like how
would you react to that uh you know what
i mean and i think it's like really
immersive in that sense and just the way
they shot it too was kind of brilliant
because
it really ramps up the suspense because
like i said you know yes even though you
know it's a giant monster but because
this is just one person with a camera uh
they don't really see the monster all
that well like really you don't get a
very good look at it until toward the
end of the movie and i think that was
like a really good
uh decision and i liked too that the
monster clover who's [ __ ] gigantic
it looks really cool by the way yeah the
monster design of this is really good
but clover also has these little
parasite things that are like all over
his body essentially i guess they're
like remoras like on a shark or
something like that and uh but they can
like jump off and run around they're
kind of spider-like or scorpion-like or
something and uh they're they bite and
it's poison which is how marlena ends up
biting it
no pun intended i actually was just
gonna say that's how she got killed but
then i said biting it i was like okay
i'm leaving it so that has like
a smaller threat too that can be
anywhere so i thought it was like kind
of good because obviously like a big
giant monster that's fairly easy to
avoid because you can like kind of see
it and hear it but then it has like all
these little bitty minions that can kind
of be anywhere and will also kill you so
i think that was like a good
balance you know what i mean so yeah so
uh so yeah they're going back in and
trying to get uh trying to get beth out
they actually do find her in actually
what is one of my favorite sequences a
lot of people when they talk about
cloverfield they talk about their
favorite or the scariest sequence being
when they decide that to be safer which
is actually not a bad idea uh that
they're going to walk through the subway
tunnels like up to you know so the
monster can't get them like on the
surface and uh you know so they don't
get shot by the military accidentally or
whatever uh so they're gonna go through
the subway tunnels but then it turns out
that the subway tunnels are full of
these little
of the little parasite uh creatures so
that doesn't work out as well as they
intended but uh and that's a great scene
too but honestly my favorite scene is
when they get to beth's building
and her building has sort of like half
fallen against another building
and uh they're like oh [ __ ] me it's like
really and so they end up having to go
up to and she's like on the 37th floor
or 39th floor or something like that
and so they have to go end up going into
the intact building next to it and climb
up to the roof and then climb out on
this [ __ ] slanted ass
roof and then climb down the buildings
like all slanted and it's like that gave
me such
anxiety because like i have horrible
horrible fear of heights
and so if i see anything like that in a
movie even though i know it's not real
it really it just makes an my stomach
just knots up like that so like the
whole time like they're crawling out
like the window and it's like onto this
[ __ ] roof and it's all slanted and i
was like oh god
i can watch i was like really really
anxious like watching that the whole
time and i was just like please don't
and then they're like looking out over
the city and they can see the bots
they're like far away i'm just like oh
[ __ ] that [ __ ] that i'm just saying you
live that far up in the thing i'm not
saving your ass i'm telling you that
right now
walking away the [ __ ] up there up on a
[ __ ] uh skyscraper roof yeah as i
mentioned earlier it's kind of
interesting because i feel like maybe
people that are younger nowadays because
i have seen some
uh
reviews of this by way younger
reviewers
that
acknowledge that this is obviously
uh kind of based around 911 or you know
inspired by 911 is that a weird thing to
say i guess but they don't really
i don't know i i guess they they know
that but it doesn't really maybe like
hit the same because you have to think
this movie came out only seven years
after that
and a lot of the shots in it are
absolutely taken from like real footage
of like 911 and the fact that this
happened in new york city and they're
framing it from
the perspective of just regular new
yorkers who are going about their life
and then this horrible like big [ __ ]
disaster happened and some people were
filming it and like people are walking
around the streets big [ __ ] clouds of
ash and smoke and [ __ ] like that coming
down the street
so
uh it's kind of interesting that
well you know because the godzilla
movies and so it was deliberate because
the godzilla movies obviously
particularly the first one gojira which
was kind of like talking about uh you
know the the atom bomb
and kind of the dangers of like you know
the post nuclear age and everything like
that and so it's kind of like the
monster being a metaphor for that and so
the fact that this movie cloverfield
kind of using
911 imagery from 911 like as the
backdrop of this so you can see that
it's kind of trying to do the same thing
as godzilla i don't know if it was quite
as successful because godzilla i think
works better
as a metaphor and obviously it's a a lot
more enduring kind of thematic metaphor
because how many godzilla movies have
there been i don't even know it's a lot
um whereas this movie seemed like
a really good movie but it didn't really
seem to
have the same like thematic res yes they
were using the monster sort of as a
metaphor i don't even know if i'd call
it a metaphor but they were just kind of
like using imagery from 911 you know
like a big scary thing happening like
i'll win and everybody like freaking out
about it so it didn't really have
anything
all that
important to say about
you know about that day or about the
attack so i think maybe that's why it
doesn't resonate the same way that maybe
godzilla does with people
but that said it's still a pretty damn
good movie and it's especially a pretty
damn good monster movie and a pretty
damn good found footage movies one
actually one of the best found footage
movies i think and like i said that's
coming from someone that doesn't love
found footage movies usually uh you know
i i kind of like mockumentaries more
than found footage but if found footage
is utilized effectively which i think it
absolutely is here then i think it
really does lend something to it i
really do think that
the found footage
uh format
really did
make this a way better movie honestly i
think if you just made this like a
regular
big monster movie
it would have been good probably but i
don't think it would have been quite as
i don't think it would have been quite
as compelling because you wouldn't have
felt like you were right in the middle
of this giant [ __ ] monster attack
so now there have been a couple
i hesitate to call them sequels because
they're almost kind of like movies that
were like set in the same universe so
you had 10 cloverfield lane and then you
had the cloverfield paradox now
i have not seen either one of those
although i'm kind of familiar with the
lore it kind they kind of explored more
of the lore around the creature and
around the situation rather than being
like a continuation of this story now jj
abrams has teased for many years that he
wanted to do a direct
sequel to cloverfield and he's kind of
hinted that what he would want to do
was that he's like well if you see
cloverfield the original movie uh
sometimes like in the crowd shots and
stuff you'll see somebody else you know
over there in the crowd like filming the
[ __ ] that's going on and he's like so i
kind of like the idea that
we can do like the same
uh event but from someone else's
perspective because obviously everybody
that it happened to would have had like
uh you know the same thing was going on
but they would have had a different
perspective on it uh so he kind of
thought that would be like an
interesting idea for a sequel
and they i don't know they keep hinting
at it but i don't know if it's ever
gonna get made i don't really know
i kind of feel like the consensus like i
said like i said i haven't seen the
other two cloverfield movies i've just
seen this one i feel like
cloverfield 10 cloverfield lane seemed
to get i remember seeing trailers for
that but i don't think i ever saw the
movie i remember that getting kind of
like mixed reviews some people thought
it was really awesome some people not so
much
cloverfield paradox i remember that one
being pretty negatively received
although
uh you know who knows just just from my
like limited perspective i'm not going
to comment because i haven't seen either
one of them so i don't really know but
as but like i said they weren't really
sequel sequels in this they were just
kind of like in the expanded
universe and i felt like the third one i
heard kind of went off into like
multiple dimensions and stuff which okay
i don't know so i'll probably end up
seeing them at some point but uh for now
i just think this is just i don't know
this is just a really good monster movie
you know an american godzilla if you
will i really do like the found footage
the way it was utilized in this uh in
this context i really like the monster
design
and uh you know it's it's just like a
really good immersive
anxiety-inducing it's very tense it's
very fast-paced and i just i don't know
i just thought it was like uh really
well done i don't know how much
it i don't know how much re-watchability
it has necessarily but it's actually
it's just like a good fun
scary you know it's pretty scary movie
uh you know in that genre so i'll give
it that but yeah uh if you've seen
cloverfield or if you've seen the other
ones and you have any opinions on those
i'd be interested to hear them because i
haven't seen them you know and what did
you think about
the viral marketing campaign which
actually i thought was uh quite
brilliant and actually uh very effective
because this made a [ __ ] ton of money on
a very very small budget oh i will say
too that even though all most of the
stuff is cgi there is a lot of practical
stuff um they did build puppets of like
the little parasite creatures uh but
they didn't they ended up using them on
screen sometimes but they said when they
were attacking people it just looked too
dumb so they went with cgi in the end
but they did actually build them so they
know what they look like and they did
build like some miniatures of the big
monster and stuff they did film a lot of
stuff in new york city although some of
the stuff they had to film on a sound
stage and then they had to kind of like
green screen uh you know farther down
streets and everything like that but
honestly it looks pretty damn good i
have to say the cgi looks pretty [ __ ]
good found footage helps with that too
because it doesn't have to look as you
know ultra hd you can have it look kind
of gritty and that actually just adds to
the realism so uh yeah so i have to say
they did a really good job like with the
small budget that they had but yeah so
let me know what you thought about
cloverfield and that will do it for this
flickers of fear continuing on with
monster march and i will see you guys on
the next one
bye